it isn't just Tom Hon's charm that's
carrying the second season premiere of
Loki though it does help but there are
also some Powerhouse lines of dialogue
that help viewers make sense of all the
time bending developments warning
spoilers for the second season premiere
of Loki ahead the nor god of Mischief is
back for another season of the Disney
plus Marvel original series Loki
following the events of season 1 Hon's
Loki and safia Martino Sylvie are no
longer on speaking terms the Kang
variant he who remains who like all
other is played by Jonathan majes is
just decaying remains at the End of Time
the time variance Authority now knows
that every single one of its agents was
hired through kidnapping memory wiping
and brainwashing with the tva's power
structure in shambles it's up to the
trickster guard and his assortment of
allies to prevent both the TVA and time
itself from unraveling into total
Oblivion much like the temporal Loom
Loki season 2 even in just the first
episode gets convoluted it's task with
weaving an incredible amount of
information into something digestive
able and concrete and much like the
temporal Loom it struggles to handle the
increased narrative load but even in the
midst of confusion the writing staff
manages to deliver some memorable lines
of dialogue that remind audiences while
they keep tuning in for one all my life
I've always handed down the same verdict
guilty and the timekeepers deemed it so
that is call Loki season 2 questions the
reach of authority is it right or even
helpful for the TVA to prune branch
timelines essentially committing
genocide all in the name of protecting
the sacred timeline is it right or even
helpful for someone to do the same to
the TVA and are such decisions not an
act of playing God Hunter B15 played by
one M mosaku certainly think so pleading
with her superiors in a meeting with the
judges Council to put a pause on pruning
her words fall on some deaf ears but
they're a much needed wakeup call for
others judge Gumble takes a revelation
of her origin as a stolen variant hard
realizing that she's condemned other
variants to death for falling outside of
the same parameters she does when the
judge makes a statement audiences
understand that she's broken free from
her brainwashing and it's that Clarity
that means so much more because judge
gamble can so easily be swapped out with
a number of real life authority figures
everyone watching Loki season 2 can
conjure up some leader whether political
religious or corporate who could do with
a similar reality check the idea of a
power figure realizing the ramifications
of their actions is so idealistic that
it's almost too fantastical even for
Marvel but only time will tell if judge
gamble follows through on her new
worldview later in the episode after a
particularly confusing conversation
about time slipping between o Wilson's
Mobius and TVA Tech guy or a Boris
nicknamed OB and play by Ki Hoy Kwan the
latter says wow that makes perfect sense
there's no flaw in that logic ob's
demeanor is so pure his tone so genuine
and his smile so friendly that it's
almost impossible to criticize him for
being the mouthpiece of a seemingly
self-aware production team yes the line
is funny because Quan is funny but it's
also funny because it's so obviously a
moment of lamp shading or calling
attention to something confusing and
then just moving on while lamb shading
can be used to great effect in the form
of meta jokes it can be used to bypass
necessary narrative explanations with
this line coming so early in the season
it feels as though Marvel Studios is
plainly informing audiences that
critical analysis will not be tolerated
and that's frustrating because again
it's coming out of Quan's mouth an
objectively talented and funny guy how
dare Loki make us feel conflicted
emotions about that man would' better
move on before we get too HED up after
killing Kang variant he who remains
Sylvie lands in Broxton Oklahoma in a
branch timeline a McDonald's employee
asks her what she'd like to eat she
answers not squirrel not Pome not rats
something that's already dead and
nothing with a face please the best part
is that she delivers this list with
practiced EAS as if she's rattled it off
a hundred times before in a hundred
different places leaving audiences
wondering whether variance some
McDonald's serve living rodents and how
often she's been offered food with a
face still attached it's silly gross
writing the kind of fits perfectly in a
superhero TV series but it's also smart
because no one here Sylvie recite these
boundaries without immediately knowing
that somewhere some when she's
experienced a few of these situations of
course that's down to the acting too
Sophia de Martino appears tired and
resigned here all except for when she
remembers to punctuate her request with
her please and that raises more
questions why does she make sure to ask
politely what happened when she
[Music]
didn't